podría estar en peligro el derecho legal
al aborto en eeuu un documento filtrado
del tribunal supremo- sugiere claramente
que el caso roe versus wade sería
anulado por los jueces de tendencia
conservadora dejando sin efecto casi 50
años de protecciones constitucionales y
precedentes legales en el borrador de
una opinión mayoritaria obtenido por el
sitio web político el juez conservador
samuel alito escribió que la histórica
decisión roe versus wade 1973 que
concedió el acceso nacional al aborto
fue atrozmente errónea desde el
principio y que row y case deben ser
anulados y continúa afirmando que no
existe un derecho constitucional a los
servicios de aborto y que debe dejarse
que los estados decidan los
manifestantes a favor y en contra se
reunieron rápidamente frente al tribunal
supremo pero no se van a salir con la
suya permítanme decirlo no me importa lo
que tenga que hacer pero no van a hacer
esto en washington y no van a hacerle
esto a eeuu somos más que ellos y vamos
a luchar
me apasiona ser pro-vida y sólo estoy
aquí como una observadora para ver cuál
es la actitud y una especie de testigo
de la historia según político el
borrador es de febrero y fue en
respuesta al caso ante el tribunal que
desafía la prohibición de misisipí sobre
el aborto después de las 15 semanas no
está claro si el borrador es la palabra
final del tribunal sobre este asunto ya
que durante el proceso de redacción los
jueces han cambiado sus opiniones los
derechos reproductivos en eeuu están
amenazados desde hace décadas y si el
tribunal supremo revoca la ley brou casi
dos docenas de estados tienen leyes en
activación que entrarían en vigor
prohibiendo el aborto la filtración ha
conmocionado a unos eeuu polarizados que
se preparan para las elecciones de mitad
de mandato del próximo otoño y que no
está en sintonía con la mayoría de los
estadounidenses recientes encuestas
muestran que sólo el 30 por ciento
quiere que se prohíba el aborto mientras
que el 69% se opone